paru surtout durant cette crise c'est
que la parole médical était et coupe la
parole scientifique était extrêmement
divisée et la difficulté si vous voulez
c'est que nous avons eu un exécutif à un
gouvernement qui a indexé sur sa prise
de décision sur finalement la façon dont
les scientifiques et des médecins à les
éclairer
disons les choix à effectuer sauf que la
grande difficulté pour les scientifiques
est que pour les médecins
c'est qu'ils étaient confrontés à un
phénomène qui était en tout cas
irréductiblement nouveau sur le plan
j'allais dire biologique donc il ne
pouvait pas apporter des réponses fermes
claires et définitives qui sont les
réponses qu'attendent les politiques en
fonction de la pression d'opinions
publiques donc en effet cette
incertitude scientifique elle n'a fait
que nourrir
l'incertitude politique et la certitude
de la prise de décision politique
alors ensuite bien évidemment moi je
rejoins tout ce qui a été dit sur la
crise de l'état c'est à dire la crise
des moyens qui est apparue de manière
très visible du fait de politiques
budgétaires qui sont des politiques
techno managériale qui ont été menées
depuis maintenant des décennies dans ce
pays
la crise de l'organisation également qui
est absolument centrale c'est à dire que
ce qu'on a vécu c'est un absolu
l'absence de coordination des services
entre eux durant en amont et durant
toute cette crise qui est d'ailleurs un
j'allais dire un facteur que l'on
retrouve dans toutes les crises et s'il
ya un point commun à refaire d'ailleurs
entre la crise que nous avons vécue et
la crise de juin 40 si je puis dire
c'est bien ce point essentiel c'est à
dire cette absence de coordination et
cette absence de moyens pour faire
preuve pour faire face à un ennemi à
l'ennemi en l'occurrence est un ennemi
invisible et un ennemi giral donc je
crois que véritablement la tâche du
politique était extrêmement compliqué du
fait de l'incertitude scientifique du
fait de l'héritage de politiques
publiques qui sont conduites dans ce
pays depuis de très nombreuses années et
puis le dernier point qui est essentiel
c'est qui on est aujourd'hui face à des
opinions publiques qui sur les questions
sanitaires et on l'a vu récemment lors
de différentes crises sanitaires qu'ils
s'agissent de la crise de la canicule en
2003 qui saisissent de la crise h1n1 en
2009 est extrêmement sensible à la façon
dont le coup
type à réagir
[Musique]